écoutez dans un contexte national
extrêmement compliquée puisque comme
vous l'avez vu dans la plupart des
régions de france le front national est
devant ce qui veut dire que nous avons
su faire passer notre message le faire
entendre
c'est déjà pour nous une première
satisfaction dans un contexte où des
régions dans lesquelles on considérait
que le front national serait largement
derrière il est devant donc nous ferons
partie probablement des trois seules
régions françaises où nous serons en
tête au soir du premier tour se réserve
des différents éléments qui arriveront
dans quelques minutes
c'est donc pour nous une vraie
satisfaction